I have a secret to tell you guys I have
diarrhea
uh sir say I don't know or maybe I do
I just forgot to record the intro part
of the video and this is what we're
stuck with because love me
[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube now on
social media there are a lot of comments
that we always see over and over again
when it comes to stuff like the Bookface
tumblr door and and its water hey you
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about and
this is aside from the LMFAO's the lol's
and the once Elizabeth why the face is
that what types of comments phrases and
acronyms they get under my skin on
social media that I see on a regular
basis are the ones that don't make any
sense
what am I do what am i what am i what am
i but that song is so [ __ ] stupid I
didn't know that if you just repeat a
word
four thousand times in one song it would
be like a 40 million hit let me do that
same [ __ ] to quarry a quarry a quarry a
quarry a quarry that weren't enough
quarry a quarry it didn't work out
no but anyways here two things that I
see on social media too much that annoy
the [ __ ] out of me
I keep on doing this number one TFT
thanks for the invite dot-dot-dot
you passive-aggressive mother but let me
tell you something there are a few
reasons why you were not invited and
it's really that simple number one I
didn't think about you when I went
through said restaurant and that eight
said food you did not come to my mind
this does not reflect on our friendship
it just means that I was fixated on that
bowl of ramen that double cheeseburger
french fries the flail fish what are you
gonna responsibie McDonald's you we need
to have a top look quick and if you want
it to come why didn't you just say hey
Dawg you hungry you mind if I come
through - if we're homies don't you
think I would have been like hey [ __ ]
yeah what do you think I was gonna say
no get a ticket the book is how's your
eyes the fingers out joke but and take a
bag of bricks and smash your face be
number two maybe I just didn't want you
there one time I went to Home Depot and
this girl texted me and said T s TI
[ __ ] whatever thought you were busy saw
you at Home Depot kill yourself die
that's [ __ ] up you Home Depot you
wanted me to invite you
to Home Depot how about this the next
time I love the Home Depot how about you
come along with me so I can build
yourself some common sense you [ __ ]
idiot out what I hate those friends that
feel that they have to be included in
everything and it's they're not they
feel like you hate them well there you
go
the next time [ __ ] wiped my [ __ ]
I'll give you a call Tom guess what I
did yeah white my butthole hmm
keep it up [ __ ] you ain't gonna be
invited to [ __ ] call me girl I'm just
kidding it's just a plug I don't don't
[ __ ] B I've done I love you here's a
common insult that I always beat on
social media
ah but you don't get but the most common
in self said to any male youtuber out
there is that phrase but a dog is that
really an insult let me break this down
for you everything a lie should have a
purpose right so by you saying that what
the [ __ ] does that prove
can't tell you some real quick saying
that you can get into a girl's vagina
will not help you get into a girl's
vagina in other words if you have to
tell people you get [ __ ] it means you
don't get busy and on top of that that's
not offensive towards me that's
offensive towards women you [ __ ]
sexually derogatory [ __ ] pictures you
tell me are you gonna put that on your
resume oh by the way he's only the third
line if you read on the qualifications
ah get perfect and on top of that the
fact that you can stick your dick into
the opposite sex does not make you
special that's human nature you want a
[ __ ] cookie this ain't no credit
score you dumb [ __ ] the higher the
number you ain't gonna get [ __ ] that's
like a girl coming up to me and saying
by the way in my life I have suck so
much dick you don't even know mmm okay
here's a breath mint and some holy water
now get the [ __ ] out yeah it's the
funniest thing on earth to me that
somebody would go out there way to write
on somebody else's page that they're a
[ __ ] both are twisted because only
gentle [ __ ] would say [ __ ] like
that Dave did you get a job now I
[ __ ] but you know I've got that
boom boom
word how you gonna pay your bills [ __ ]
bill we come out just sleepy had too
much sex do you think my real [ __ ] here
we go Oh what is going on YouTube thank
you once again for tuning in I like
doing these end videos now because I'm
like interactive with you guys and I'm
actually talking to you like this you up
there like this and yes those were a
couple things that I've been saying that
that kind of irritates me gets under my
skin on social media now if you guys
have another couple things that are out
there cuz I know there are a lot more
that it pisses everybody off let me know
write it in the comments send me a
message I don't know maybe I'll talk
about it next time but once again
clothing is always brought to you by
coal from broke apparel this sweater you
cannot get because it was a little
special thing I made for myself however
if you guys want it who knows we might
bring it out no no but once again every
Wednesday make sure you guys tune into
the fitness blogs which is coming up in
a few days and it's going to be a weekly
upload so you will get two times two
David two times the fun you know I'm
saying if you get sick of me [ __ ] you
chop your face off
what anyway see y'all in a few days and
once again see y'all next Sunday so
peace that's so fruity as hell oh hey I
got me pre into the most high like
Sydney in his prime I'm a bad truck